so we just got to our shooting location
and we're doing a client project today
have you been here before
no
have you no so pretty
so now we're trying to film the steam
coming up through the golden light
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
wow my hair is
officially haven't showered in
five days last night there was a
succession of gunshots that were
uncomfortably close to the van at
about two in the morning and it actually
sounded like someone was knocking on my
van it was that close that kind of
freaked me out we have a house starting
tomorrow that's for three weeks which
i'm pretty stoked on because santa fe is
a place i've always wanted to explore
and it's in this beautiful house it's a
photographer
they have a really cute cat and it just
looks like that
very modern traditional
santa fe new mexico style so yeah really
excited for a little bit of slow down
and right now just uh
as usual trying to find
another place to sleep
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
i was really looking forward to this
slowdown
it was long overdue after so many
consecutive months on the road
and i was just craving all the creature
comforts that come with staying in a
house
quiet
rest
warmth
stability
and of course
hot baths
foreign
i took it back
[Music]
i saw what i
[Music]
and my dreams are
outer space to see
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
so
[Music]
i typically wait until i'm doing a house
it or i'm staying at an airbnb with a
washer and dryer to clean my cushions
because
they don't really get that dirty so i'm
going to do it like every i don't know
the most six to eight months but
it's hard to dry them when you got to
sleep on them every night so
i do it when i'm staying at a place
so i can wash them and then let them air
dry this is the cushion
that is the hardest to get on and off
because there's only a zipper on each
side there isn't a zipper the length of
the cushion
and i'm always so afraid that i'm gonna
break the zipper because it's
it seems kind of fragile to me but
actually do i even need to watch this
one
it seems kind of fine
military russian aircraft just
entered to ukrainian
airspace and then
throw down three bombs
it's really starting to separate
here between the tile and the wood so
trying to scrape off the excess and then
i'm going to go in and do my best to
re-cock this tile
as a friday a senior u.s official
[Music]
this is so hard to do without a caulking
gun
i did have one but i threw it away
because
it takes up a lot of space and i'm
really wishing i hadn't done that it
does not want to come out
so let's widen out the lens how are
things looking elsewhere living on the
road can be a lot of work
throw in a full-time creativity-based
career and the combination can easily
become a chaotic and unsustainable
existence
i do struggle with it sometimes which is
why i really value these pet tits
their pockets of stability and my
otherwise unpredictable life
also because i would love to have a pet
of my own on the road but with the last
minute travel my job and the amount of
time i spend in national parks protected
wilderness areas overseas
it just doesn't make sense right now
one day i do want a pet of my own again
but for now i squeeze in all the
snuggles i can get
[Music]
you do
[Music]
kind of mysterious
[Music]
day two of our shoot
and today's color theme is yellow and
navy
so we're working with
lemons i'm gonna pick up a few flowers
and i am wearing a yellow tank top and
blue jeans
thank you
they're so pretty
so it is actually march right now
and there's snow out on the ground you
can kind of see it but we have to make
it look like summer
so i've been wearing a tank top we're
doing like summer colors and themes but
it's actually really freaking cold
you shouldn't even be complaining
because you get to wear a sweater the
whole time
day four hello
we're going to find some green
[Music]
we are doing kind of ketchup concepts
today
we need to get more photos and we have
different themes
color themes and again
we need to make it look like spring and
summer
but
as you can see there is snow
everywhere so
should i bend the knees
point the toes
[Music]
just ruffle them up a little bit
okay
okay your toes appear now nathaniel's
the foot model
that's right
i've been replaced
i take matters into my own hands
wow one advantage of living on the road
full-time is access to a variety of
unique locations both for myself and the
clients i shoot for
but when i'm pet sitting options are
limited since i never want to leave the
pet for too long
also if i'm somewhere new i'm not really
familiar with the location and the best
places to shoot
so there's always a bit of a trade-off
stability but limitation versus
instability but opportunity
it's a balancing act most of the time
but with some planning and a little bit
of luck it is possible to have both
even on the road
[Music]
we spent the rest of our time editing
and making the most of our last few days
with iggy and once everything was done
and submitted we both agreed that it was
finally time to relax and do a whole lot
of nothing
but just two days later that plan was
turned upside down and we found
ourselves heading to the nearest airport
but more on that in the next video
thanks for being here
and i will catch you guys next time
is that your new hangout spot